26 rich на марушевська Юлія вчили знайти
одеську та ми знайти його на член команди
реформаторі
одеського губернатора Михайла Саакашвілі
видно його планам марушівської мої зуби на
це контрабанду топ обороти корупцію в
своїм побачимо будемо зимин з самого
душа керрі в Метт води і мити знайти в
очі вийди за мало нарікаючи cool ішня
рамочка активістка
яга вловимих знайти при значило
заступника
люди ну запах яну ковача з душі денної
біографії you i wanna мої статті вид
побачили за б ручку ставок і контрабанди
візьму і з води
його надіслав пан насиров і це дуже димно
по видно до
грушевська і куманда відкрито
протестуйте проти вірно ні та влада
корупціонерів ладу системи з окликають
переконатися та інших засіків за видами цієї
мають рацію під кальку руб ти це хабар
спорідненості намито знайти тепер можна за
телефон вашої на гарячу лінію депутат
не монте-карло бундестагу ганс йоахім
факти про суп з сокири кунов шістьма
переб'ю реформу на успіх не вказуючи на
причини корупції українців можна
влада iv столітті скінчена активно у сунуть і
біг ще противником такого не платять
чого не носила може запустити чит і
свої і знову на неї товар-то поторгуватися
пробилися ефективно роботу противники в
адміністрації та потрібно красти пакети
таки ми можемо враховувати ту штуку руб
тобі вирішено модеми такого значення
каддафі
запорошено набути за ситуацією у тачок піти
реформ і за сотні в одесі та на зимовий
інвестори
ой капела monkey рівний до оператора
контейнерного терміналу одеського порту
і поки що українця це дочірньої заповзятливо
німецької компанії іноземним інвесторам
завершуємо в роті віри ти в моїй
ті україни і наші ніхто не вкладає ти ми
сюди простіше відомо за раз я п вниз
цвинтар наприклад
9 оголення нацбанк ще до дивідендів
грушевий наказ про
замок та стабілізації ситуації на сході
вкрадені економічні проривні приносить
нас і буду в ручок від і прогнозу я
німецька їжа лиж в
team хто виносив виграші реформатори
чіпси тиша корупціонери